[موسيقى]
غادر بعدها مباشره لانه اشتاق الى زوجته
نانسي وهذه قصه اخرى حيث منعتها سلطاتنا
من مرافقته
بين
لانهم كانوا يعرفون انها ستشجعه على
البقاء وكان هناك جماعه في الولايات
المتحده لم ترغب بحصول ذلك وتاليا منعها
من السفر وهذا اغضبها كثيرا حيث اتصلت بي
وهي تصرخ تلك المراه تلك المراه الا ان
رايسا لم تكن مذنبه ابدا
الحقيقه هي ان ما حدث كان ماساويا حيث ان
غوربشوب ترك لمقابله اكثر من 2000 صحفي
كانوا في الانتظار وقد كتب في مذكراته انه
كان متاثرا جدا ولم يعرف ماذا يفعل لكنه
فكر في الامر وادرك انهم في الحقيقه حققوا
شيئا كبيرا لم يحققه من قبل وقدم كلمه
جميله جدا وقد كتب احد الروس عن ذلك فقال
ان نانسي اجهشت بالبكاء بينما كانت جالسه
في الصف الاول النهايه كانت حزينه جدا
ونحن لم نتحدث عن زيارته للمزرعه والوقت
السعيد الذي قضاياه معا هناك
اتصلت بي وهي تصرخ هل تعرفين ما فعله
السيد جورب فسالتها ماذا فعل فقالت انهم
رفضوا منحه تاشيره زياره فسالتها اولا
لماذا انا متاكده ان علاقه السيد غوربات
جيده جدا وقالت نعم ولكنهم رفضوا منحه
تاشيره زياره لابنها الذين نسيت اسمه
والذي كان يعمل مع برنامج اذاعي القصه قد
تبدو مضحكه ولكنها في الحقيقه حزينه ما
حدث هو ان روسيا قالوا انهم يقدمون مسرحيه
عنوانها امريكا مع تغيير حرف في الاسم
انت تقصدين ران الابن
نارون جماعتنا قالوا فقط ان الروس رفضوا
منحه تاشيره زياره
[موسيقى]